SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY. THAT IS EIGHT
J. R. FOURTEEN WHICH IS ON
CONSENT. AND WE HAVE A QUORUM
AS OF RIGHT NOW ALSO WE WILL.
ALL GO AHEAD AND MAKE A MOTION.
CALL ROLE. ROLL THE GUEST WE
WILL GO AHEAD ESTABLISH. PLEASE
CALL RICARDO. HER TITLE HERE
STONE STONE HERE BELL BILL HERE
JACKSON PAN PAN HERE WIENER.
FOR OKAY GREAT. SO WE DON'T
GREAT SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
MOTION IS AFFRONT TO BE ADOPTED
AS AMENDED. US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I RICARDO AYE
STONE STONE I KNOW. BELL I
JACKSON PAN PAN AYE WIENER WE
HAVE FOUR. SO WE HAVE THE BILL
IS FOR AND WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPENED TO ALLOW
OTHER MEMBERS. OPTION ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT
. THE ROLE.
JACKSON. JACKSON I JACKSON AYE
WIENER. FIVE ZERO THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO WILL CONTINUE TO
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
. NUMBER TWO.
YEAH SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND OPEN
UP THE ROLE ON A TO YOUR
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ARE FOURTEEN
LACKEY THE MOTION IS THE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WIENER WIENER HIGH SIX
VOTES SO THE VOTE IS SIX ZERO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND NOW CLOSER
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THIS AND ARMY TO PROTECT